negative stereotypes we heard about each
other's ethnicities
I heard that Taiwanese people are
extremely extremely cheap
is that true oh yeah it's actually a
true one I always hear the Japanese
people are perverts they are Japanese
Americans don't speak Japanese but
that's true my grandpa back in the day
he's an old Chinese dude and he like
served in the military he would ask my
sisters you guys got any friends that
are Japanese and my sisters were like no
he goes good
oh what what does that mean yeah dude
it's hardcore though my Korean friend
was having a sleepover we were all
playing but I couldn't stay and I had to
go home whoa yeah because I was Japanese
and then their grandma didn't like that
sorry you can't stay and I was like why
uh my grandma doesn't like that you're
Japanese I was like telling my mom I was
crying and they're like oh well
yeah or she's like again something bad
to their Grandma so don't worry we'll
kill them later what's